بينما تقوم روسيا بتجميع قواتها لشن حربها
على اوكرانيا كان لابد
لنا ان نستجيب وسويه
او فينا بوعدنا شكرا لكم على وقفتكم شكل
الامر فارقا كبيرا
وسويا
او فينا بالوعد
وقمنا بتقديم الدعم العسكري
وخلف الدعم العسكري هناك الدعم المعنوي
الذي قدم لاوكرانيا
فقد احدث فارقا كبيرا
حتى على مستوى داخل البلاد من حيث الانفاق
الدفاعي
وكنا قد عملنا
عصويا على
تزويد اوكرانيا
بالمساعدات العسكريه الضروريه من حيث
الاسلحه الدفاعيه والدبابات وقد كذلك
عملنا على الوفاء بمتطلبات اوكرانيا
الاساسيه مثل الغذاء
حلف النيتو ماض في عزيمته ووحدته اكثر من
اي وقت مضى في كافه انحاء اوروبا هذا ما
كنا قد تحدثنا به في السنه الماضيه شكرا
على استضافته مره اخرى
ودعني اقول
انها سنه سنه مهمه بسبب المخاطر مخاطر
الحرب التي تاتي من روسيا في اوكرانيا لذا
من الضروره ان نعمل معا
وان نقدم الدعم الممكن والعمليه لاوكرانيا
وفي هذه الاوقات ارى من الضروره بان نبعث
برساله باننا مستمرون في نفس المسار مهما
استغرق الامر من وقت
واننا لن نغير موقفنا البته في دعم
اوكرانيا وانني اثمن
صراحه حسن التعاون فيما بيننا وبين
الولايات المتحده والمانيا واوروبا فهذه
العلاقه وشراكه تعد في افضل احوالها اليوم
وانا سعيد لاكون هنا للتحدث معك بمزيد من
التفاصيل في هذا العمل